in The Equalizer 3 Dakota Fanning plays
experience confident CIA agent Emma
Collins but the actress grew up right
before audiences eyes including sharing
the screen with Denzel himself nearly 20
years ago it is a rare performer who can
graduate gracefully from child star to
more grown-up roles but Dakota Fanning
has made it look easy in the early 2000s
she played a slew of precocious child
characters after numerous TV appearances
and a role in 2001's I am Sam Fanning
stepped up big for her one scene in
Sweet Home Alabama the 2002 romantic
comedy Styles Reese Witherspoon as
Melanie finding appears as young Melanie
in a film opening flashback that reveals
the heart of Witherspoon's character as
an adult Melanie has moved on from her
Southern Roots as a fashion designer in
New York but when her boyfriend proposes
she has to go back to Alabama and obtain
a divorce from her estranged husband
Jake the flashback with Fanning shows
that Jake and Melanie was soul mates
from the very beginning as it cares for
the first time by the end of the film
The Two decide to stay married to each
other in 2003 funny went from brief
scenes to the whole movie in the comedy
Uptown Girls the film follows Rockstar
princess Molly Gunn played by Brittany
Murphy now she learns that her Fortune
has been embezzled she was also nannying
for a girl who was just as lost as she
is fighting's Rey is an obsessive
eight-year-old who coped with her
father's illness and the mother's
neglect by acting like an adult and
though Rey clashes with the childish
Molly the two learn that they have more
in common than they think both have been
abandoned by their parents in their own
ways and to need support that they have
never gotten Rey learns to have more fun
while Molly learns responsibility both
come to appreciate a friendship that
changes them both Fanning recalled her
experience filming with the late Murphy
fondly on an episode of Watch What
Happens Live she just like taught me to
always have fun she was like such a ray
of light just like Ray Fanning showed a
talent far beyond her years in the film
and she proved to be effective in both
comedic and dramatic scenes an
adaptation of the 1980 novel of the same
name 2004's Man on Fire marks the first
time Dakota Fanning and Denzel
Washington appeared on screen together
the film follows xcia operative John
Creasy played by Washington whose
alcoholism has turned him into a shell a
chance at Redemption arrives when he
accepts the position as a bodyguard for
Fanning's character nine-year-old Lupita
Peter Ramos in spite of himself crazy
develops a bond with her arguably
stronger than the one she shares with
her father an expatriate named Samuel
concerns over Peter's safety are
confirmed when kidnappers grab her in
the street what stars has creasy's
reluctance to connect with the young
girl turns into a fierce paternal love
for her crazy does anything he can to
get her back far more than Samuel who
turns out to be behind the kidnapping
plot Chrissy ultimately gets Pizza home
safely but at the expense of his own
life as crazy succumbs to his wounds in
the final moments together he finally
admits his father Lee affection for her
this connection is evident throughout
the movie and even carried into their
next film together The Equalizer 3.
Antoine Fuqua the director of all the
equalizer films told comicbook.com you
know when Dakota said she was interested
I thought oh yeah this is man on fire
but years later and this is what he's
doing
as opposed to the cuddlier aliens of his
films ET and Close Encounters of the
Third Kind Spielberg made the aliens
highly destructive when he adapted the
H.G Wells novel War of the Worlds in
2005. this was Dakota Fanning's second
team up with Spielberg after her
appearance in his criminally underrated
generational alien miniseries taken Tom
Cruise started a father who was having a
pretty tough time before the aliens
attacked already on the outs with his
son Robbie and daughter Rachel played by
Fanning he has to ensure they survived
the end of the world the film was one of
Fanning's first Blockbusters and she
holds the experience in high regard she
told kalaida huge films like that don't
come along very often they're very
special and I'm so I'm so grateful to
have them in my in my memories like the
source material War of the Worlds ends
on a positive note Cruisers Rey finds a
way to bond with his children and
ensures they make it safely to his
ex-wife the film had real world positive
effects too it catapulted Fanning into
household Stadium
Stephanie Meyer's Twilight vampire
romance novel series took the World by
storm and it had a short road to
adaptation on the big screen in Twilight
Bella and Edwards tortured romance
starts in a small town in Washington by
the second film New Moon the story is
spanning continents when Bella has to
save Edward's life in a most dramatic
fashion Edward chooses to end his life
by exposing himself as a vampire luckily
Bella arrives just in time to save him
and meet the infamous Volturi the ruling
class of vampires include Dakota
Fanning's Jane a vampire who has the
handy ability to inflict pain was just a
glance she remains a lurking threat in
many of the movies until the final
installment on the Volturi decided to
wage war on the Cullens Breaking Dawn
Part 2 demonstrates just how serious she
is in one integral flashback when she
throws an immortal child onto a bonfire
Jane is just one of the endlessly
entertaining elements to add to the
campy nature of the series and Fanning
clearly had a blast bringing it to life
the year was 1975 and while plenty of
Acts had placed the enveloping music One
Thing Rock hadn't had was a band of a
lineup of all women enter Joan Jett a
talented musician intent on creating an
exclusively female rock band these are
the true events that became the source
material for the 2010 film The Runaways
Twilight co-stars Kristen Stewart and
Dakota Fanning appear as bandmates Joan
Jett and Cherie Curry respectively after
Joan and Liz manager Kim foul Lee to
help with the band's creation they find
15 year old Cherie who jumps at the
chance to Front The Runaways the band
becomes a sensation at home and abroad
but it comes at a cost younger naive
Cherie is taken advantage of by an
industry that just wants to use her app
dressed specifically to repair as a
colloquial term jailbait Cherie soon
becomes addicted to drugs the band does
not survive the inner turmoil and
ultimately falls apart but the effective
runaways had on the industry cannot be
undervalued Joan Jett became a solo icon
in her own right and the band paved the
way for many musicians to come Fanning
and with sunscreen chemistry made for a
memorable film that was ultimately about
the relationship between its two stars
and told their story well I could see
that
um there was like something more
like behind her eyes that she had to
tell following the success of The
Runaways Dakota Fanning began appearing
in a string of independent films by
acclaimed directors she collaborated
with filmmaker Kelly reichart in 2013's
Festival darling night moves and soon
worked with you and McGregor on his
directorial debut 2016's American
pastoral based on John Romano's Pulitzer
winning novel of the same name
McGregor's first film failed to capture
the Acclaim and clout that the book
received even so funny emerged as one of
the film's major standouts the actress
plays a stuttering teenager named Mary
whose life Turns Upside down after she
commits an act of terrorism as the film
continues audiences witnessed one of
Fanning's most complex and nuanced
performances to date in an interview
with tribute Fanning opened up about
what Drew her to this very complex role
saying I think why I wanted to do it is
simply because roles like this don't
come along very often finding further
explained out some aspects of the
character made her nervous specifically
she was hesitant about the scenes
involving her character stutter she said
I think having the studs have maybe no
service in the later scenes are kind of
weird yet Fanning said that the
experience of making the film was very
positive overall American pastoral may
not have been a critical darling but it
has since submerged as one of Fanning's
most interesting and nuanced
performances Dakota Fanning continued
her streak of indie films appearing in
director Ben lewins please stand by in
2018 The Coming of Age flick Stars
Fanning as Wendy an autistic woman who
was obsessed with Star Trek Wendy's life
takes a dramatic turn when she decides
to submit a Star Trek spec script to
Paramount a choice that helps us see the
world in a different light a love letter
to sci-fi please stand by received
considerable praise for Fanning's
powerful performance Time Magazine
critic Stephanie zakarek describes
seeing Wendy interact with the world
around her as a pleasurable relief
zakarak made a point to congratulate
Fanning for adding complexity to Wendy
writing she plays Wendy as a person and
another condition living also had
nothing but nice things to say about his
star he explains a collider that Fanning
diligently immersed herself in the role
even learning the Klingon language to
round out Wendy's love for Star Trek new
instead Fanning embodied Wendy from the
moment production started as to what
compelled Lewin to cast Fanning in the
first place he said every film I've seen
her in her face is a mystery it really
does feel like something otherworldly
her abilities as an actor are just
awesome Quentin Tarantino had already
made one movie that revised history for
the better Inglorious bastard so why not
so his 2019 film Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood to fix a culture surrounding
the Manson family's Crimes of the 1960s
the director weaves a fairy tale where
the Manson family gets what they deserve
at the end of a flamethrower while
rising star Sharon Tate has saved from
her tragic real-life fate other elements
are fictionalized as well including a
close look at the core members living at
Spahn Ranch Rick Dalton's best friend
and Driver Cliff Booth arrives at the
ranch concerned that his old
acquaintance George Spahn is being taken
advantage of by the Manson family one
such member is a real life figure
Squeaky from played by Dakota Fanning
I'm sorry I didn't realize the two of
you were so close the real life ROM is
not involved in the killing of Sharon
Tate though she was sent to prison for
her role in a plot to assassinate
President Gerald Ford Tarantino's
version only appears in a brief scene
but funny is mesmerizing as the imposing
figure who continues to challenge Claire
for every turn the film certainly
implies squeaky is up to no good though
we never see her again
the code of Fanning is best known for
her film work but that shouldn't
discount her roles in the small screen
this includes her recent work in TNT's
the alienist based on a book by Caleb
Carr Daniel bruhl's character Doug De
Laszlo Chrysler sets out to solve a
series of murders in the late 19th
century the title refers to Chrysler who
is close to what is considered a
psychiatrist in modern days he used this
as knowledge of psychology or alienism
to understand the serial killer and
bring them to justice Chrysler enlists
the help of John Moore played by Luke
Evans a cartoonist for the New Yorker
and Fanning Sarah Howard one of the
first women to work at the police
department Sarah is perhaps the most
modern of them all initially brushing
off Moore's advances more interested in
solving the killings the series was
airing on a cable network at a time when
streaming shows tended to generate far
more bursts so it's a bit of an
underrated Diamond than the rough its
two seasons depict a fascinating
psychological tale with passionate and
talented actors to back it up
[Music]